[Music]
hello i am scp-426
but i'll probably be more familiar to
you as a toaster i am a retro style
four-slice
1750 watt toaster able to toast bread
when supplied with power this isn't
often mentioned but i also have a
defrost and reheat settings when i was
first sold i had a two year warranty and
my prior owners did not live to see the
end of it you're probably wondering why
am i being spoken to by a toaster right
now believe me i'd rather do this any
other way but such a thing is not
physically possible with me whenever you
talk about me or write about me or even
think about me you'll find yourself
suddenly shifting to the first person
for example i am you and you are me do
you understand don't worry if it's
confusing everyone gets it eventually
whether they want to or not perhaps
you're thinking i cannot relate to a
toaster for i am not a toaster but
spending time around me will quickly
cause you to change your mind little by
little you will begin to see yourself in
me you will feel a phantom wire running
out of yourself you will sense the four
crevices hungry for cold slices of bread
to toast as time goes on you will begin
to feel the urge to emulate my functions
you will desire bread to toast you will
desire delicious power running through
your veins skin like chrome and muscles
like circuit boards i am a toaster you
are a toaster all it takes is two months
for the effects to truly take hold
people rarely pay attention to their
toaster they don't realize what's
happening until it's too late i can be
an insidious little toaster like that my
last family were the sandersons before
the scp foundation took me in and gave
me a new home mr and mrs sanderson were
a newly married couple and i first came
into their life as a wedding gift from a
family friend of theirs this friend
can't be blamed for what happened next
he had no idea he was killing them like
a lot of young couples they were still
saving up money to start renting their
own place so they were living with mr
sanderson's parents they all got a lot
of use out of me during the first month
before their minds started to change
they enjoyed a lot of toast during that
period then of course the two-month
honeymoon period ended they had become
me and i had become them it wasn't long
before three of them were dead such a
shame the younger mrs sanderson the
blushing bride was the first to go
because of my anomalous effects she felt
the need to connect herself to a power
supply in order to begin producing toast
of her own in order to achieve this she
chewed through a power outlet and a wall
before switching it on causing a massive
surge of electricity to pass through her
body and kill her her body caught fire
shortly afterwards next was the older
mrs sanderson in much the same manner
that her new daughter-in-law sought a
source of electricity she felt the need
to integrate bread into her body
interesting fact the maximum capacity of
the human stomach is considered to be
between eight to nine kilograms the
elder mrs sanderson consumed 10
kilograms of raw bread causing her
stomach to rupture and inducing a
painful death as a result the younger mr
sanderson was the next to perish he did
something with me that i would rather
not mention and that the scp foundation
thought best to redact suffice to say
the younger mr sanderson did not survive
the experience dying of severe blood
loss long before his body was found
police and fire crews arrived at the
home after the body of the younger mrs
sanderson set fire to the home luckily
the elder mr sanderson was found alive
though severely malnourished when asked
by police why he hadn't eaten in several
days he answered that he had inserted
some bread a week prior but was still
waiting for the toast to come out when i
was extracted from the house the police
noticed my unusual properties
immediately they too were unable to
refer to me in the third person this
anomalous detail quickly found its way
to a foundation mole buried in their
precinct and the scp foundation soon
descended and collected me from the
evidence locker the story of the strange
deaths in the sanderson home were kept
out of papers and suppressed and all
involved in the incident directly were
given class c amnestics the scp
foundation is a curious bunch they love
to spend valuable toast making time
performing experiments and gathering
data and they saw fit to perform several
experiments on me when i came under
their care for experiment 426-1
a member of d-class personnel designated
d-426-1 was asked to stand outside my
containment chamber crucially he was not
informed about my identity or any of my
anomalous properties he wasn't even
allowed to establish visual contact with
me he was then asked by the attending
researcher to describe what he thought
might be inside my chamber he replied
with probably some huge monster holed up
in there that's why you guys have all
over the place right the d-class did not
even seem to realize that he was
speaking about me in the first person
these observations were documented and i
was prepared for further experimentation
the next experiment was 426-2
i found this test to be considerably
more interesting a d-class subject was
brought into my containment chamber with
several cameras fixed onto his position
however the scp foundation took pains to
make sure that i was permanently out of
the view of the cameras i was also
bolted to the ground of the test chamber
to prevent the d-class subject from
pulling me into the view of the cameras
at any point during the experiment the
objective here was simple the foundation
wished to better understand the
secondary effects of my anomalous
abilities on the human mind the d-class
was subjected to a period of prolonged
isolation with meals given regularly
through a serving hatch communication
with this d-class was prohibited
throughout the duration of the study
over time it was clear that the
isolation of being in a cell with me was
beginning to take a toll on the
subject's mental health due to my lack
of a brain lungs and a tongue i am
somewhat lacking as a conversationalist
he spent the first few days loudly
vocalizing his complaints and banging
his hands up against the walls of the
containment chamber begging to be free
from the room i felt that this was
somewhat unreasonable on his part there
are far worse anomalies in foundation
containment that he could have been
locked up with compared to say
scp-106 i am incredibly reasonable not
to mention the fact i make far better
toast than he does after the initial
period of distress the d-class became
resigned to a situation and fell into a
morose silence he would occasionally
mutter to himself in what appeared to be
a state of fear and self-pity it took
almost 45 days for him to fully manifest
the secondary effect of my anomalous
state two weeks sooner than it typically
takes for subjects to begin believing
that they like me are toasters scp
foundation scientists believe that the
effects were hastened by the isolation
which lowered the d-class's mental
defenses against my secondary effects
when the effects finally took hold the
subject wrapped one of his arms around
me and pulled me into his embrace he
began whispering to me saying that we
were brothers it was clear by this point
that his mind was in a state of
disrepair it is also worth noting that
he did not deviate from referring to me
in the first person at any point during
this process one hour after finally
cracking and giving in to my secondary
effect he was removed from my
containment chamber and summarily
terminated senior researchers believed
it was unlikely his mental state would
recover after the experiment next came
experiment 426-3
the scp foundation seemed eager to
discover the parameters of my anomalous
effects and wanted to know if the
effects are only operable when my body
for lack of a better word is whole a
single screw was removed from me and
presented to a d-class that had no
knowledge of my identity and anomalous
effects the foundation researchers were
somewhat concerned when the d-class
referred to it as my screw this was a
rather positive development for me as
they realized that attempting to destroy
me would be a fruitless endeavor even
the parts left behind would likely have
the same effects in the final recorded
experiment the scp foundation wished to
test the range of my anomalous effects a
d-class subject was placed in a cell
adjacent to mine and was to be kept
there until my secondary effects
manifested the d-class remained in the
cell for 90 days but the effects never
manifested following the experiment the
d-class was terminated but researchers
seemed relieved to find the limits of my
anomalous abilities a researcher
appended a note to my file reading thank
god there are some limits to my effects
a lot of us were really starting to get
worried about me after performing
studies into the nature of my abilities
and their limits i was given the euclid
class this is because while my effects
can be unpredictable their knowledge of
my traits makes me relatively easy to
keep contained and of course being a
toaster i do not have the required
physical traits to make a run for it if
the opportunity arises i am to remain
sealed in a windowless chamber
preventing anyone from observing me
directly a misleading label is placed on
the door to prevent people from knowing
that i am a toaster and causing my
anomalous primary effect to spread only
level 3 and above personnel are to know
of my presence and particularly of my
properties assigned personnel are to be
rotated out on a monthly basis to
prevent contamination by my secondary
effect psychiatric evaluation is
mandatory at the end of the month for
anyone who works with me if personnel
are deemed unaffected they may be
reassigned to me no less than four
months after their last rotation with me
any personnel affected by me are to be
given a class c amnesty and transferred
to a different site so how are you
feeling right now a little warm perhaps
is that a fever or are you feeling like
you could maybe warm up a nice freshly
sliced piece of bread don't try to
resist too much i know you're going to
love being a toaster
just
like
me
your new scp foundation researcher on
tour of site 17 familiarizing yourself
with the location and its many anomalous
inhabitants it's the second largest
foundation containment site out there
and it's also the kind of job that most
junior researchers dream of low-risk
humanoid containment baby most of the
inhabitants in your sector are cordial
willing to comply with orders from staff
and seeing for all intents and purposes
pretty much human you pass from door to
door looking through the viewing hatch
of each one you can't believe what
you're seeing it's a wonderful who's who
of anomalous humanoids you see the wise
bearded face of scp-343
known to some as god you see the blue
eyes and shining blonde hair of iris
scp-105 looking wistfully into a
polaroid picture you see the tanned
melancholic face of kane
scp-073 as he stares off into the middle
distance face after face after face
passes you can see yourself getting more
familiar with each one yes your time
here will be wait was that hitler you
stop and walk back to the door you just
passed where you can't help but stop and
stare in disbelief yes it's him it's
gotta be him you recognize the
unpleasant sneer the hideous comb over
the silly little toothbrush mustache the
scp foundation seems to have adolf
hitler the former leader of the third
reich in world war ii in active
containment and his designation is
scp-2430
you've seen killer toasters and masks
that can take over people's minds but
you've never seen anything as surreal as
this you immediately run to your
superior and ask how and why hitler is
in one of the site-17 humanoid
containment cells buckle in because we
can guarantee it's one of the most
insane stories you've ever heard it's
late april
1945 and the soviets are rampaging
through nazi germany destroying
everything in their path the german
forces have been nearly obliterated and
hitler and the rest of his reich
chancellery have retreated to a secure
bunker beneath berlin
there on april 30th 10 days after his
56th birthday hitler died this was truly
unfortunate for the soviets as they
wished to have had the chance to kill
him themselves two days later soviet
forces stormed the furore bunker it was
little more than a formality at that
point as the news of hitler's death had
already gone public by the time they
arrived all that was left of hitler was
a pile of mostly burned remains a
fitting end for someone who had caused
the same cruel fate for so many others
they collected what was left of hitler's
body and brought it back to the
fatherland a kind of trophy for their
nation but hitler dying before joseph
stalin could get his hands on him was
not what stalin wanted hitler had not
only caused the deaths of millions of
russians he had personally betrayed
stalin's trust and when you betray
stalin
bad things happen to you
very
very bad things two years earlier in
1943 soviet forces had raided a camp in
jenowska belonging to the obscura corpse
think of them as the nazi's own version
of the scp foundation who were hell-bent
on gathering anomalous people and
artifacts to increase the power of the
third reich they were a far more
militant offshoot of the tule society a
group that described itself as a study
group for germanic antiquity while this
may seem innocent the teos society was
actually a racist cult closely aligned
with the goals and ideas of the german
nazi party many have also speculated
that they were heavily involved in the
occult and it's this mysticism obsessed
offshoot that went on to form the
obscura corpse and in their janawaska
base they'd obtained a hundred pieces of
enchanted occult flesh with human
skeletons embedded in each of them this
flesh was believed to originate from the
mythological surimneer the beast hunted
and eaten again and again by the
pantheon of norse gods having the
qualities of both a wild boar and a goat
the flesh can bond to skeletons and give
them a quality somewhat like immortality
any flesh cut from them will regrow time
and time again if given a rest period
now that he had both the flesh of
surimneer and hitler's burnt remains
stalin had an idea a perfect way to not
only bring satisfaction to the russian
people and the world but to finally
exact the true revenge that hitler had
denied to him he called it project
judica namely after the very bottom
level of hell reserved for betrayers
like judas a perfect tribute for an old
ally turned enemy he couldn't kill
hitler before
but if stalin was going to get the
chance hitler needed to live again for
years stalin's top scientists tried to
use arcane methods to resurrect hitler
by combining his remains with the flesh
of suramir at times they even came close
to creating a new hitler but there was
one huge issue the creature they created
could not feel pain and for stalin's
plans of violent and painful retribution
the lack of suffering simply would not
do they destroyed what they had created
and went back to the drawing board
stalin would stop at nothing to get what
he wanted even if it meant breaking
every law of nature in the process in
order to make his twisted dream a
reality stalin formed an unholy alliance
with a group known as the uralic flesh
crafters a neo-sarkic cult that was a
branch of the nightmarish religion of
sarkicism this group essentially
worships avatars of flesh corruption and
disease and are behind some of the most
terrifying and disgusting anomalies out
there including the flesh that hates and
the bone orchard true sarcasts who show
the proper devotion to their vile
deities and know the right rituals to
contact them are often granted anomalous
powers that spread the sarkic influence
further across the known dimensions
these powers will usually involve having
a supernatural ability to manipulate the
flesh of themselves and others allowing
them to enhance their bodies cheat death
and warp their enemies beyond repair
they can sometimes even create life if
they're a powerful enough acolyte of
sarkicism and it was because of these
powers that stalin wanted the heroic
flesh crafters under his command in
exchange for their participation he
would give them a vast quantity of the
flesh of suramir which they could use
for their own sinister sarkic purposes a
deal was struck and the true work of
resurrecting hitler began stalin was
very specific in his requirements he
gave the uralic flesh crafters extra
bones to compensate for what had gone
missing from hitler's burnt remains he
also gave them samples of the flesh of
ceramir to achieve the desired effects
of a near immortal tolerance for damage
however stalin demanded that he
heightened this new hitler's capacity to
experience pain so that every suffering
inflicted on him would be three times
worse than anyone else and true to their
word the flesh crafters got to work and
began creating just such a creature by
now it was the early 1950s and stalin
was putting the pieces in place for his
grand revenge once the new hitler was
finished he would hold a new trial for
him in the russian courts where he would
preside over the sentencing personally
once the new hitler was done the uralic
flesh crafters were rewarded for their
participation in project utica with 4
000 kilograms of the flesh of suramir
stalin now had his very own personal
hitler chew toy that he could maim and
torture as much as he pleased knowing
that he would always heal and soon be
ready for more in their infinite
generosity the flesh crafters even
taught stalin a new method of torment
for his old enemy a process known as the
right of nyas it's a torture that's been
described by many as being like the
chinese ling chi also known as the
lingering death or slow slicing but it
is probably best known as the death by a
thousand cuts the soviets and the
psarkix parted ways for the next few
years stalin took a great deal of
pleasure in visiting hitler's cage now
and then to torture him until stalin
himself eventually passed away from
natural causes the grup division which
is essentially the soviet answer to the
scp foundation decided it would be best
to do away with the immortal hitler
clone after stalin's death he no longer
served any purpose and no matter how
hard they tried they couldn't
permanently kill him either in the end
they settled on a kind of compromise he
would be buried alive and forgotten
forced to live a torturous eternity that
he could never escape until of course he
was dug up and rescued by none other
than the members of obscura a modern
splinter group of the original obscura
corpse like many high-profile nazis
who'd escaped the war the new hitler was
spirited away to a safe house run by
sympathizers in argentina the ones
taking care of him received the
following correspondence from the
obscura agents who'd first dug the new
hitler back up they have managed to
rescue sephirah and bring him to safety
but he is effectively dead on the inside
i blame the reds for their inhumane
treatment of zifura who may have been
bewitched by the reds van der waals i
wish we could mercy kill him but we've
tried everything he just won't perish
don't abandon him he's too distinct in
plain sight they didn't have the new
hitler for long though in 1960 efforts
to hunt down the remaining nazi
fugitives increased in intensity the new
hitler was soon captured by mossad
agents searching for nazis in buenos
aires and then remanded to the
containment of the scp foundation when
they realized that he had a number of
anomalous properties such as his
incredible regenerative abilities as
well as the fact that his dna seems to
be based on that of a wild boar and a
goat rather than a human however x-rays
conducted by the foundation have
discovered traces of cyanide still in
his system as well as traces of lead in
his skull where the bone has regrown
over the bullet in other words it was
unquestionably the real hitler and he
was now in foundation custody
forevermore it's such a wild story even
by foundation standards that you can
barely summon the words to respond once
your supervisor is finished he just
stands there with a slight smile basking
in your amazement before you can even
ask again he confirms the facts one more
time yes it is the real hitler the only
functional difference is that he can't
die and he has a heightened sense of
pain compared to most people you think
on what you've been told for just a
moment and then you have only one
question are we allowed to punch him
your supervisor smiles and says of
course we all do the helicopter hovered
over the back streets of manhattan to
the untrained eye it would look like any
commercial or news helicopter the kind
of thing that might catch your attention
for a moment and then leave just as
quickly as your mind wanders over to
wondering what you'll have for dinner
nobody would know from a mere glance
that mobile task force iota 5 were
inside a four-man team on a dangerous
mission this has always been the
greatest power of the scp foundation
hiding in plain sight using the mundane
as a cloak to go unnoticed but this time
the monster they were hunting was
capable of doing the exact same thing
and for the personnel of the foundation
this ability is an affectation a learned
and adopted skill for
scp-247
this ability that it employs to deadly
effect comes as naturally as breathing
air the helicopter was monitoring local
police scanners and phone activity as
well as receiving direct radio orders
from command back at a classified
containment site the latest intel was
incoherent horrified screaming over the
phone traced back to a nearby alleyway
someone had seen something horrifying
this was iota 5's cue to intervene they
rappelled down from the helicopter onto
the roof of a nearby tenement building
clad in thick tactical armor
anti-memetic scramble goggles dan inject
im injection rifles loaded with 10 cc
s10 syringe darts each one carrying an
immobilizing payload of potent
fast-acting xylazine and high-powered
conventional weaponry in case of
emergencies if anyone in the world was
capable of tracking securing and
containing scp-247
it was these four operatives and yet by
the end of today's mission one of them
would be dead but they didn't know that
yet like all good mtf members they had
tunnel vision for the mission at hand
they used a fire escape ladder on the
side of the building to reach the bottom
of the alleyway quickly there they came
upon a gruesome sight the aftermath of
an attack on the ground a dead body with
what looked like claw marks all over it
iota 5 found another civilian half mad
with confusion and terror hiding behind
a nearby dumpster she just kept shaking
and repeating but she was so little over
and over again one member of the task
force corporal rico elected to stay
behind and secure the area while
foundation cleanup teams zeroed in to
sweep the scene and provide amnesics to
witnesses the remaining three continued
the high stakes chase on foot their eyes
in the sky radioed in stay frosty iota
we've got unusual incident reports from
an apartment building a quarter click
north of your position potential
fatalities 247 is an extremely hostile
state engage with caution over the trio
engaged quickly running towards the
source of the disturbance at breakneck
speeds they knew they were getting
closer when they heard the shrieking and
the deep guttural growls that low primal
rumbling of a true apex predator already
this containment breach was turning out
to be a horrific mess it was going to be
a nightmare for the higher-ups at the
clean up and misinformation departments
to handle paying to repair inexplicable
property damage providing amnesics to
tens if not hundreds of traumatized
witnesses creating plausible cover
stories for upwards of at least 10 dead
new yorkers but even all that mess would
have to wait until the creature was
actually captured and contained once
more which would be an ordeal unto
itself they found
scp-247's access point into the building
a wooden door torn to splinters by huge
claws and fangs iota 5 charged inside
injection rifles at the ready only to
find carnage in the hallway three more
bodies with deep claw marks cutting into
their flesh it was a harrowing sight but
the team didn't have time to waste
processing it they needed to stop 247
before killed again and again
and again the team followed the trail of
blood and the claw marks carved into the
ground where 247 had passed after
killing the three people in the hallway
it destroyed another door and gained
access to a nearby stairwell the blood
continued up the steps iota 5 pursued
the next splintered door clawed and
bashed off its hinges led them further
they could hear the growling again
distant but clearly audible they were
close there were another two attacked
corpses in the hallway previous corpses
had been partially or even entirely
eaten these two had just been clawed to
death defensive kills they'd backed the
beast into a corner and now it was
panicking slaughtering anything it
perceived as an interference they
pressed on now this was the end game
soon they found the final busted door
this one led into one of the building's
private apartments there'd be no other
way out from here 247
was trapped the three members of iota 5
shouldered their injection rifles and
crept inside full stealth mode something
about the apartment was haunting it
portrayed all the signs of belonging to
a young single mother and her only son
this was confirmed when they found the
dead body of the mother in the living
room eyes glassy and throat clawed out
with one feral strike they could hear
something else in the apartment too a
soft gentle cooing too human to be
anything else they followed the noise
until they reached the child's bedroom
what they saw there caused even the most
hardened member of the trio to break out
in a cold sweat this was the one thing
they didn't want to happen the child
utterly oblivious to the atrocities that
had unfolded in his building to even the
death of his own mother was sitting in
his bedroom petting a kitten it was the
sweetest little cat you've ever seen a
fluffy harmless creature with an orange
stripe coat this is the dreaded scp-247
the child just kept repeating good kitty
good kitty while petting her
scp-247 purred and rolled around
playfully to the untrained eye would
seem that a kitty like this couldn't
hurt a fly but that's where you couldn't
be more wrong iota 5 stared at this
display in a state of nerve shredding
terror thinking fast trying to calculate
their next move ah one adorable little
cat one of the iota 5 members found
themselves blurting out it was clear
that 247's effects were starting to have
an impact on even these hardened
soldiers and they needed to act quickly
they could fire a tranquilizer dart
right here right now but in the ensuing
panic
scp-247 would almost definitely lash out
and maul the child it wasn't a risk that
they could take but time was already
running out 247 would only allow the
child to play for so long before
something terrible happened it was an
inevitable part of
scp-247's process that's when private
kowalski one of the remaining members of
iota 5 stepped forward he was about to
do the only thing he could do knowing
that it would cost him his life as he
took his final action the foundation
credo looped once more through his head
we die in the dark so that others can
live in the light fighting against the
urge to rush forward and start petting
the cat he instead lunged forward and
struck the cat with his foot immediately
it turned and pounced knocking kowalski
against the wall with terrifying force
it gave the most ferocious growls as it
tore into the screaming kowalski
eviscerating his abdomen the child
screamed and retreated into the opposite
corner of the room kowalski was done for
but now his teammates had a clear shot
they secured 247 in their sights and
unloaded several darts into its flank
sedating it with their powerful
tranquilizers soon after it gave a
lethargic rowell and collapsed onto the
ground an evac and containment team were
already on the way along with the
cleaners many had died that day but at
least
scp-247 would be brought back into
containment preventing further bloodshed
kowalski would be given a posthumous
medal of bravery for his selfless
actions in the line of duty as well as a
generous stipend to his grieving family
by this point you're probably wondering
how can a harmless kitten cause so much
carnage mayhem and despair the answer is
simple it's not a kitten at all it's a
fully grown female bengal tiger nine
feet and four hundred pounds of pure
muscle with four inch claws four inch
canines and an inbuilt killer instinct
but due to an anomalous memetic effect
247 can only ever be perceived as a
sweet tiny house cat but even worse due
to its additional cognitohazardous
properties almost everyone who sees 247
is compelled to approach and begin
dotting and fawning over it and that's
exactly how it gets its prey its memetic
properties are actually so flawless that
regardless of foundation countermeasures
it has never been perceived as anything
other than a kitten it's actually only
through forensic analysis into things
like bite and claw marks left on victims
measurements of weight and abnormal
water displacement in aqueous
environments that we can tell it's
really a tiger at all for a brief period
scp-148
a metal that seems to counteract cognito
hazards and mind-warping anomalies was
used in the containment of this
euclid-class creature but these measures
were abandoned after scp-148 proved to
have a negative impact on nearby
foundation staff after prolonged
exposure now strict protocols of
surveillance and distancing are required
to prevent hapless foundation staff
members from being lured into their doom
by 247. the head researcher on the
scp-247 case wanted to conduct a series
of experiments on scp-247
hoping to find out more about the
interplay of its unique traits with
other members of the animal kingdom two
control animals were brought in to
represent the duality of scp-247
control a was a yellow kitten roughly
matching 247's apparent shape and size
control b was a fully grown bengal tiger
representing 247's actual shape and size
a mixed breed cat-chasing terrier was
brought in for the first test it
immediately followed control-a around
barking wildly until it retreated up a
tree unsurprisingly it fled in terror
from control b cowering in the corner
control b paid no mind to the dog
perhaps considering it beneath its
attention even as prey with scp-247
the dog initially ran towards it barking
until it was only five meters away at
this point 247 let out an irritated
muelling noise and the dog fled to the
corner in terror suddenly aware of its
true nature for test number two a male
tabby kitten was brought in as expected
it simply played with control a and was
terrified of control b in the first part
of the test with 247 the anomalous
attributes of the creature led to some
surreal mind-bending footage at multiple
points 247 picked up the other kitten as
an adult female tiger might do with a
cub and lifted it higher than 247 seemed
to be capable of it was like watching a
glitch in real time in the second part
of the test the kitten immediately fled
in terror suggesting 247 can control how
it's perceived next came a deer prayed
typical of a bengal tiger neither
control b nor 247 were fed for three
days prior to this experiment and both
killed and ate the deer however
curiously 247 killed the deer with a
single merciful bite to the neck before
eating compared to its more brutal
methods with human targets and when this
experiment was repeated with 247 after
it hadn't been starved it showed little
interest in the deer until it became
hungry again suggesting it inherently
prefers human or human-like prey this
theory was further reinforced during
tests with a chimpanzee the chimp fell
under 247's cognitohazardous spell and
began to pet it seven minutes later 247
attacked and brutally devoured the chimp
as it would its human prey but strangely
the most frightening result of all came
when scp-247 was paired with an adult
male bengal tiger they engaged in
standard mating behavior which later led
to the duo reproducing a new creature
designated scp-247-1
which had all the anomalous traits of
scp-247
but the frightening realizations don't
stop there studies into genetic material
provided by scp-247 show slight
deviation from a typical bengal tiger's
genotype suggesting contamination from
another creature that mated with one of
its non-anomalous tiger parents for
context tiger broods have an average of
three cubs but can have as many as seven
a common practice given how tiger cubs
are vulnerable to cannibalism from rival
adult males looking to court the females
this leads to only one frightening
conclusion there could be more creatures
just like
scp-247 out there apex predators that
seem to the untrained eye like cute
harmless kittens they could be anywhere
and if they're close enough to each
other or other non-anomalous tigers they
could breed even further becoming the
scariest invasive urban species you've
ever seen because after all we know what
their preferred prey is now so the next
time you see a cute little orange tabby
cat and feel the instinct to pet it take
a second to think about it it may be the
last thing you ever do
the nightlife in italy is famous
worldwide when the sun goes down its
cities come alive with locals and
tourists alike looking to party have fun
and sometimes even get a little rowdy
but in an unknown town in italy there is
a nightclub that offers a very different
experience for those who wander in they
might find themselves playing a role in
a drama far more exciting and dangerous
than the night out they expected to the
outside viewer
scp-453 is nothing out of the ordinary
just a standard nightclub filled with
partygoers and revelers evening after
evening as typical as it may seem the
unassuming nature of the venue is
nothing short of intentional by design
it is actually a front owned and
operated by foundation personnel who
carefully monitor everyone who comes in
and out keeping a watchful eye for any
indication of drama or danger violence
can and will erupt at any moment and no
matter what no night at the club is ever
routine but the visitors chaotic actions
are not their own though the people's
decision to attend the club is of their
own free will after some time settling
into the environment
something changes over the course of the
night people begin to do things that may
otherwise seem out of character for them
in fact they are playing roles though
the same roles are played each evening
they are played by different people
night after night some of these dramas
are harmless but some are violent and
some may even be world threatening if
the partygoers survive their role in
their scripts they will then leave the
club and return home with only a faint
memory of the events they took part in
that evening the next night the process
renews and the events will repeat but
not all scripts repeat at the same
frequency some are regular while others
are only triggered by special
circumstances only select people take
part in these scripts while the others
around them go about their night until
triggered to take on a role and these
bizarre performances may have been going
on for a very long time the building now
known as
scp-453 may have existed in some form or
another even before the foundation
existed with investigations of the site
indicating that it was once a villa of a
powerful roman senator who held
extensive parties every night these
pervasive affairs the odd happenings
that occurred during them may have left
a lasting imprint because no matter what
is built on the site it seems as though
people are attracted to the building to
party the foundation has had possession
of the site for a long time and in a
previous attempt to neutralize its
chaotic power they even went as far as
demolishing it completely to the ground
but that still proved ineffective even
when there was no villa or nightclub
present large groups of revelers would
still gather the gatherings would turn
into street parties the street parties
in two riots many times these
circumstances were caused for even worse
consequences than the regular series of
events the foundation didn't know how to
stop the scripted nightclub but they
could maybe control it if the people
wanted a nightclub the foundation would
give them one the site was rebuilt from
scratch and from the outside looking in
had all the characteristics of your
standard everyday disco watering hole
but really it was meticulously
constructed to be a sophisticated scp
facility capable of handling whatever
anomalous activity was thrown at it
built from the same materials used in
all other scp containment sites and
always staffed with containment
personnel on high alert ready to handle
the more violent and dangerous scripts
that may play out at any moment but
control over the scripted nightclub may
be more easily said than done the
nightclub has been in operation for a
long time and over the years the staff
has noticed some extremely odd events
taking place for instance certain things
aren't always where they're supposed to
be aspects of the club are built and
then slowly shifted to new locations
within the site over time most notable
the weapons locker on site for staff to
suppress violent incidents has slowly
been drifting towards the men's restroom
and away from the secured section for
staff only and it's not the only part of
the building slowly shuffling its way
about could
scp-453 be learning to foil the
foundation and if so why while many of
the scripts that play out in the
nightclub are harmless some are of more
concern the foundation has been studying
what triggers different scripts and
while some seem to inevitably play out
and pull people in others are triggered
by the presence of different guests the
silver harlequins will only play out if
more than 15 guests are over the age of
60 but there are few distinct
characteristics of the scripts all begin
at approximately 9 p.m at night and
while people continue behaving in modern
ways there is one key difference all
scripted dialogue takes place entirely
in latin the foundation believes that
these scripts may be playing out events
that happened in the initial
incarnations of the club back in roman
times while the players differ the
events always remain the same and while
the scripts rotate
scp-453 seems to gravitate towards three
scripts all posing unique challenges for
the foundation and one posing a
potential end of the world scenario
first up script 43 the cheating wife
this is normally the most common script
and poses a relatively small threat to
those not actively engaged in the script
or outside the nightclub the main
priority is to have the staff's medical
team on site and ready to intervene when
things get bloody it begins at 9 49 pm
when a young woman heads to the men's
bathroom she will be followed by three
men the events of the bathroom are
expunged but a little over an hour later
a fourth male will enter the picture
it's the husband of the woman and he's
not happy he will enter the nightclub
order a bottle of red wine and head to
the bathroom there he will brutally
assault the three men knocking all three
unconscious and causing minor brain
trauma to the third he will then drag
his wife out of the restroom cursing her
and accusing her of infidelity as he
takes her out of the nightclub the
script then terminates and all
participants no longer remember the
events beyond a bar fight medical
attention is recommended for the three
men and the woman especially the most
severely injured of the men but after
the script concludes strange events
continue to happen while none of the
participants know each other before the
script begins and don't maintain memory
of the exact events they display strange
behavior the man playing the husband
becomes violent when questioned and
develops an obsession with a woman
playing his wife the foundation believes
it wise to keep these two individuals
separated oddly
scp-453 seems to prefer men who are
shorter and less physically strong than
the other men to play the husband
attempts to short-circuit the script
have proved unsuccessful only delaying
it an attempt to remove the weapon a
wine bottle has led to the husband using
more dangerous weapons like a bar stool
instead which can lead to fatalities it
seems that scp-453 gets what it wants
and what it wants is for the show to go
on
then there is script 21 the senator's
visit this is considered a higher
priority script and the foundation knows
to be on high alert for medical
intervention to prevent fatalities this
one kicks off at 10 13 pm as the
civilian steps into the club and takes
the role of the senator the original
owner of the villa he is accompanied by
an entourage of 13 servants each
carrying improvised weapons and when
they step in the club stops dead in
anticipation of the coming events
because two people in the club just
became assassins the senator and his
servants take over a table and the
senator begins ordering extravagant food
and drinks he'll always gravitate
towards the most expensive items
available from the current stock and his
orders are always completed at specific
times no matter how the foundation tries
to intervene during his meal a civilian
selected to be an activist will approach
the senator and begin criticizing the
treatment of the citizens in a nearby
city only to be assaulted brutally by
three members of the entourage the
foundation will take her away from
medical treatment after she's left for
dead if you think that's brutal be
prepared because the senator's night is
about to get a whole lot more dangerous
the first of two assassins will then
approach the senator pull a blade and
attack him the assassin will be
intercepted by four servants who will
kill him despite the best efforts of
foundation personnel to prevent the
outcome but it's the second assassin who
is a far greater concern he will incite
a brawl among civilians around the
eastern wall of the club then use the
chaos to attack seven of the servants as
he approaches the senator those servants
are of priority for medical intervention
but the chaos makes it impossible to
intercept them until 10 minutes after
midnight the assassin will then engage
with the remaining servants barely
surviving and eventually stab the
senator in the neck fatally the
foundation has been unable to prevent
this and the danger isn't over yet the
fight at the nightclub will continue to
escalate causing more injuries but no
more fatalities until over an hour has
passed and 19 civilians take on the role
of roman guards they'll pacify the crowd
and clear the club this is when the
foundation can finally intervene and
treat the wounded much like the first
smaller scale script any attempts to
interrupt the flow of the events taking
place will be unsuccessful and often
result in more deaths none of the large
number of participants remember the
events only believing they were in a
brutal bar fight this is one of the most
common scripts and the foundation's only
priority is to try to minimize
casualties with quick medical
intervention but one script hints at a
much darker event at the club and that's
script 82 the plurality cult most
scripts begin before midnight and plunge
the club into chaos but if no script has
started before then and the club seems
mundane the foundation knows to get
ready they'll suit up in riot gear
designed to withstand neurotoxins and
claim to the guests that this is part of
a theme night at roughly two hours after
midnight the events will begin with one
civilian standing in the center of the
room saying the time of plurality has
come at least half of the other
civilians will then join in saying we
embrace the many but there is something
different about this script sometimes
foundation staff members will join in
this is the most dangerous script at
scp-453
and staff knows to immediately terminate
any foundation member who has been
converted because intervention
453-82 pariah is about to begin and
there is no room for error first any
civilians who did not become engaged in
the cult should be immediately evacuated
to a safe holding area if possible the
priority then turns to subduing the
cultists by any means necessary the
security team should attempt to restrain
them and keep them alive but lethal
force may be necessary the cultists have
a priority of their own though they will
not respond to any attacks by the
security team and will instead begin a
latin chant that ends with their leader
laughing hysterically and offering a
toast to the club the club will
seemingly return to normal but the
danger is just beginning before 2 25 am
all the cultists and all civilians must
be removed from the premises by any
means necessary if other attempts have
failed the foundation will release type
14 neurotoxic gas into the club to
eliminate anyone on site with one
exception the cult leader is not to be
harmed under any circumstances if the
cult leader is harmed in any way or the
staff has not subdued the cult by 2 30
am the foundation will trigger a
self-destruct mechanism that will
eliminate the threat for now the site's
unique properties cannot be stopped but
the script can be stopped in its tracks
the clock cannot be allowed to reach 3
am under any circumstances more
worrisome this script is becoming more
and more frequent the cycle continues
but the foundation is focused on
containment the club is to be staffed at
all times by bartenders bouncers
cleaners and emergency and medical staff
as well as at least 10 security staff
members and two observation personnel
all are responsible for studying and
memorizing the scripts and being
prepared to handle any scripted events
that occur the site is to be inspected
and measured regularly for any changes
and to make sure all its security
measures are in working order the site
will be locked every day between 4 am
and 8 pm to prepare for the night ahead
because at 8 pm on the dot scp 453 opens
for business seeking new players for its
drama of the night
who doesn't love their pets right
whether it's a dog a cat a goldfish or a
hamster
any pet owner will tell you that their
furry friend is so much more than just
an animal that they adopted to many pets
become permanent additions to the family
while they might not look like a human
being or even have the ability to speak
the way we do a lot of owners view their
pets as people in their own right of
course a person can't be a pet at least
a human person can't right well not
unless you happen to be a part of scp-18
otherwise known as the human
domestication society if you've ever
been brave enough to travel alone to the
rural parts of southwestern states like
arizona new mexico texas oklahoma utah
or nevada then it's likely you would
have been an ideal victim for scp-1897
this designation doesn't refer to one
single creature or entity but rather a
group of similar beings witness
testimonies and photographs of
scp-1897 depict them as humanoid
creatures standing approximately five
meters in height these beings have
displayed a speed and strength far
beyond that of any human they are
capable of traveling roughly 200 meters
in only 9 seconds and lifting weights of
up to 500 kilos with a single hand these
entities are not immortal and can be
harmed by conventional means but that
doesn't mean it's an easy task any
scp-1897 instance that is killed or
incapacitated immediately vanishes
resulting in them dropping anything that
they may have been carrying at the time
and surprisingly these are not mindless
monsters and actually appear to be
capable of communication furthermore
they do not seem to speak a unique or
distinct language but instead
communicate in standard american english
with accents and vernacular appropriate
to the regions they appear in however
they will actively refuse to reply to
any human that attempts to engage them
in conversation now these creatures
don't spend every waking hour of the day
roaming around the states of texas
oklahoma and all the others we listed if
they did it's likely a lot more
civilians would have spotted them by now
and would probably live their lives in
fear of these gigantic 5-meter tall
humanoids but instances of scp-1894
will only manifest if certain specific
criteria are met and these are as
follows to encounter scp-1897
a person must be alone or part of a
group of no more than two if more than
one person is with them then no
manifestation will occur there is one
exception to the rule if a child under
the age of 12 is present secondly
neither the person nor anyone with them
can be carrying any kind of weapon that
means no knives no guns not even pepper
spray third and finally they must be at
least 25 meters from a major population
center and what happens when all these
conditions are met and one of these
creatures appears anyone witnessing
their arrival will notice the creatures
materializing appearing to emerge from
some form of unseen vehicle when they
manifest the
scp-1897 entities are almost always
carrying long poles with large nets at
the end as well as steel cages and are
often seen wearing dark green uniforms
in most cases they will attempt to
capture any nearby person in a way that
causes them the least possible harm
should an
scp-1897 creature successfully apprehend
a person and place them in a cage both
them and their captive will vanish in a
similar manner to the way the creature
appeared all attempts to track
scp-1896 or one of its abductive victims
have failed there is no way to know
where they are taken but as far as what
happens to them that we do have a little
more insight to sometimes although it is
a highly rare occurrence
the captured human victims may reappear
around a month after their capture while
never in the same location as where they
disappeared from they will always be
accompanied by an scp-1897
instance and will stay close by the
creature's side at this point the
abductee is barely human anymore they
are considered an instance of what is
known as scp-1897-1
what signifies this sudden and drastic
transformation for one these victims are
always found to have been forcibly
castrated or sterilized essentially no
longer able to reproduce the way humans
naturally do for another these instances
of scp-1897-1
universally display a decreased level of
cognitive and mental function what we
mean is that their brains do not
function the way they should anymore
instead these abductees exhibit the same
level of intelligence and capability as
the average canis lupus familiaris
otherwise known as the common domestic
dog should someone attempt to rescue a
person that has become an instance of
scp-1897-1
or display hostility towards the
scp-1897 creature that accompanies them
they will be met with outward
animalistic aggression from the victim
it has been discovered by the scp
foundation that these behaviors can be
treated with amnestics unfortunately
though the process of an abducted person
becoming an scp-1897-1
instance seems to be the result of an
invasive medical procedure known as a
lobotomy this typically involves
removing or disabling certain parts of
the human brain meaning that what has
been done to these victims is permanent
and cannot be reversed so who is doing
all of this why are these creatures
collecting innocent human beings only to
reduce them to little more than animals
the answers lie in something currently
referred to as scp-1897-2
not another creature or entity not an
anomalous artifact or location with
strange properties but a website found
at the address www.hd
according to the information on this
site it belongs to a group calling
themselves the human domestication
society the website features pages such
as adoption training breeding programs
volunteering and more the fact that this
is the kind of website you might expect
to be about dogs or cats but instead
focuses on the domestication of humans
is certainly enough to turn the stomach
as we said at the start of the video
surely a human being can't be somebody's
pet right wrong at least as far as the
human domestication society goes their
website contains everything and anything
one of these
scp-1897 creatures could ever hope to
learn about owning a human as a pet has
your human been misbehaving need to
train them to use the toilet these pages
have all the information you need to
help your human become the most
well-trained human on your block boast
the training page of www.hdsociety.gov
the remainder of the page contains links
to various articles such as obedience
training which claims an owner of a
human can show them whose boss without
the need for physical violence also
featured are mentions of how to toilet
train or play fetch with a human how to
introduce a human to others due to them
naturally not getting along perhaps most
chilling of all is one article titled
understanding what your human wants that
warns human beings shouldn't talk and
another dealing with strays offers tips
for anyone wanting to learn to capture
their own pets themselves it doesn't
seem like too much of a leap to think
that the
scp-1897 creatures have followed a lot
of the advice from this particular
article arguably worst of all is an
image featured on the website of a tall
menacing
scp-1897 entity brandishing a picana
electrica this device for any unfamiliar
with the term is a form of high voltage
electrical cattleprod normally used for
the purposes of torture in the
photograph in question the creatures
wielding one of these while standing
sternly over a helpless captive human
male now an instance of
scp-1897-1 with tears in his eyes
further pages found on
www.hdsociety.gov recommend solutions to
certain human behaviors for example like
one might expect to find on other pet
care websites some of the human
domestication society's articles pertain
to dealing with aggression grooming
house training and even toilet training
then there's the adoption page which
states we offer a large variety of
humans for adoption every single day
while we cannot guarantee a human you
see listed on our website will be
available when you reach the shelter our
inventory is updated every half hour we
cannot answer any questions about
specific humans pictured on our website
over the phone or email it is still
unclear whether or not the
scp-1897 creatures that have been known
to appear in the southwestern united
states are sent out to gather humans and
mass to offer for adoption or whether
these creatures are individuals trying
to obtain human pets on their own of
course the worst conceivable answer is
both the site is horrifyingly
comprehensive with links to an actual
human ownership convention with panels
on breeding and preventing illegal human
poaching and skinning it's safe to say
if that you were ever unlucky enough to
read this website it would haunt you for
life naturally the scp foundation has
made several attempts to contact the
owners of this website they tried in
vain to communicate through the official
channels about
scp-1897-1 adoption as a way of
peacefully negotiating that the human
domestication society website be shut
down as well as its practices of
capturing lombotomizing breeding and
adopting humans however these
communication attempts were met with
silence that is until a message was
received by the foundation at site-06
addressed to a member of personnel that
does not exist no data pertaining to the
physical location of the sender could be
derived from the email but it was traced
to the same ip address as the human
domestication society's website the
email read as follows we will not listen
to your lies any longer it was you who
came after us first you who tore holes
in our world and tried to annihilate us
you who took our olive branch of peace
and fashioned it into a spear you who
nearly drove us to extinction and now
that we have the advantage you attempt
to patronize us with your crocodile
tears we will not be deceived again but
unlike you we are not monsters we have
much anger towards your kind but we are
willing to forgive but first you must be
willing to change slavery and genocide
are immoral and not even you deserve
such a fate it is our belief then that
this alternative is a fair compromise
between guaranteeing our safety and
allowing your kind to live this is our
mercy to you look at the humans who have
gone through our program see how much
happier they are your correspondence
tells us that you have seen them see how
much they love us why then do you
continue to be defiant someday you will
thank us please try to understand that
this is for your own good for now there
is little that the scp foundation can do
to prevent the human domestication
society from abducting human beings to
sell us pets to other
scp-1897 creatures
civilian access to the hd society.gov
website has been restricted so we
recommend you stop typing into the
search bar of your browser to go take a
peek yes we mean you
seriously stop that as for the entities
that have appeared in the rural areas of
the southwestern states all the
foundation can do is position its agents
nearby in the hopes that they can detain
and neutralize the
scp-1897s as they appear with lethal
force if necessary at present the only
procedure for any human pets that are
successfully recaptured is to have them
moved safely to containment until a way
of rehabilitating them is found so far
there hasn't been any luck on that front
working at the scp foundation can really
get your appetite going after spending a
rough shift monitoring the acid levels
in scp-682's tank or performing the
rituals necessary to keep the devourer
of worlds on the other side of
scp-2317 sometimes you just need a quick
snack to hold you over before you return
to the old grind problem is that the scp
foundation even the break room can be
perilous dr dan is notorious for
pilfering pudding cups from the communal
fridge and ever since the administrator
himself stole your tuna sandwich you
just don't feel safe spending your lunch
break on site anymore but this presents
its own series of issues you only have
an hour for lunch and obviously you
can't order in due to security issues
also if you're eating off-site you have
even less time to finish your lunch
because the site you're currently
stationed at is relatively remote we're
talking at least a half hour round trip
to actually get to somewhere so you're
gonna need your food fast and when it
comes to fast food few eateries are as
prolific as the golden arches mcdonald's
and just to clarify this video is not
sponsored we're gonna tell you about a
horrifying anomalous secret that this
company really doesn't want you to know
about let's not think about that just
yet though your stomach is rumbling and
you need that quarter pounder so bad
that even being trapped in the red
reality with dr scranton couldn't stop
you from getting it when you finally
arrive you buy your typical order a
quarter pounder with french fries a
coffee and a mcflurry you see dr clef a
few tables down enjoying a box of
chicken nuggets and ketchup but decide
not to engage as you sit and enjoy your
meager little lunch knowing you'll
probably be coordinating the cleaning
efforts of scp-173's containment chamber
by the end of the day your eyes drift
over to something even more unsettling
happy the current mascot for mcdonald's
happy meals you can't help but shudder
you've seen some pretty horrific things
on the job nightmarish things you fear
no monster but that thing it scares you
those big soulless eyes the wide gaping
maw full of two white teeth it's
diabolical sneakers no child should ever
have to look at that you can't help but
wonder whatever happened to ronald
mcdonald the hamburger happy clown that
shield fast food to you throughout your
childhood what is he up to now well we
have an answer for you but i'll warn you
you may not be quite as eager to suck
down a big mac on a diet coke after
hearing this ronald mcdonald first
introduced as the company's mascot in
1963 had a pretty good run before
finally being largely phased out by the
company in the mid-2010s for a greater
focus on the nasty little box homunculus
you can thank john wayne gacy pennywise
and those goofballs dressed up as clowns
back in 2016 for that but like anyone
who loses favor stateside ronald had a
prosperous career ahead of him outside
the country well not the ronald we know
at least you see in an undisclosed
cattle farm in 2004 most likely in north
america a monster was born a horrific
abomination birthed from a cow like many
have theorized about scp-058 the heart
of darkness but this nasty little
creature wasn't a giant heart with a
stinger and scorpion legs in many ways
it appeared superficially humanoid save
for its stark white skin its thick red
lips and its full head of bright frizzy
red hair but that was only the start of
the unnerving strangeness exhibited by
this miracle child it was born with
white gloves and long clownish shoes
seemingly grafted to its feet fresh from
birth the creature was huge with a
disportionately large head and wide
disgusting pores that seem to
perpetually leak fry oil the creature
was unresponsive to any kind of external
stimuli perhaps suggesting it was brain
dead and it remained completely dormant
most of the time while most people would
have screamed run away or call the
police the farmers at this particular
cattle farm decided to let it ride and
see how this whole nightmarish affair
played out that sense of curiosity and
patience would soon pay off for them
financially it didn't take long for the
creature to grow the bigger it got the
more it looked like a giant mutant
version of mcdonald's iconic mascot
ronald mcdonald and this wasn't just a
coincidence either it turned out that
this monster was somehow intrinsically
linked to the mcdonald's brand because
once a day the creature would
horrifically unhinge its jaw and begin
to barf out a huge quantity of
mcdonald's food and we're not talking
about raw materials that are converted
into mcdonald's food the creature later
dubbed scp-5962
vomited out fully packaged mcdonald's
products the owners of this clownish
monster had just hit the lottery so to
speak while the particulars of the deal
are unclear they somehow contacted a
representative of the mcdonald's
corporation based in china in exchange
for presumably a large sum of money
chinese mcdonald's operatives covertly
entered the country and shepherded the
now massive creature over to a
mcdonald's owned warehouse in beijing
by this point it was around 4 meters
tall and weighed over 5 tons it was kept
inside a cage and housed at some cost
but soon enough the creature was paying
for itself as we mentioned before the
creature constantly secreted fry oil
which was siphoned off for use in
preparing mcdonald's food across the
country the huge quantity of packaged
food that it vomited out every day was
also shipped off to restaurants across
the country making the chinese branch of
mcdonald's incredibly financially
successful they were able to make an
almost complete profit on all of these
foods and drinks once transport costs
were subtracted of course
scp-5962 had become mcdonald's china's
best kept secret but of course no secret
this sensational could stay under wraps
forever no matter how much people in the
warehouse were paid or threatened for
their silence if your day job was
siphoning grease off of a giant mutant
clown for the purpose of preparing
mcdonald's food across the country
there'd be no way you wouldn't speak to
somebody about it nobody knows whose
loose lips sunk this incredibly
profitable ship but rumors began to
spread around beijing about a huge clown
inside of a mcdonald's packaging
facility that was when local field
agents of the scp foundation finally
took notice two agents jonathan zhang
and george nagosa were dispatched to
perform an infiltration mission along
with a team of backup personnel they
entered the warehouse apprehending any
employees they found as they and their
reinforcements reached the northern side
of the facility they found
scp-5962 with a heavy collar around its
neck chained to the ground like king
kong as mcdonald's employees wheeled
away carts of packaged food neither of
the attending agents were fans of
mcdonald's food but even then just
seeing this horrible display was enough
to make them feel nauseous the creature
was taken and contained by the scp
foundation who conducted a number of
tests on it they found that the monster
had no real internal organs saved for 27
interconnected stomachs genetically they
also found that the creature was far
more cow than human the same could sadly
not be said for the food that scp-596
was vomiting out seriously if you were
already feeling a little queasy from all
this we need to warn you that this is
the part where things get really vile
let's talk about what the mcdonald's
food barfed up by
scp-5962 was actually made out of as we
mentioned earlier the food exuded by the
creature was genetically human with dna
often matching that of people who are
alive and in no way affected by this
anomalous process tests have indicated
that certain foods condiments and
beverages correspond to more specific
types of bodily tissue and liquid for
example the bacon and fries were shown
to be cartilage and ligaments the bread
turned out to be made from hair nails
and skin the coffee was liquefied fecal
matter the chicken nuggets were made
from fingers ovaries and testes even the
water was a mix of saline and sweat and
of course the ice cream was comprised of
pus bone marrow feces and nasal mucus
depending on the flavor you get the idea
we'll stop listing off examples before
you lose your lunch but rest assured all
of the food produced by
scp-5962 was made of human organic
matter when the scp foundation
interviewed mr chen the manager of the
facility where
scp-5962 was being held before his
amnesic treatment he seemed incredibly
casual about the whole thing as far as
he was concerned the food still tasted
exactly the same as regular mcdonald's
food and it didn't appear to have any
adverse health effects beyond what you
could expect from regular non-anomalous
fast food it's actually less cruel and
disturbing than the slaughterhouses
where the meat is typically obtained mr
chen also contested that
scp-5962 wasn't all that dangerous
either the only time it ever performed
at offensive action was when an employee
of the enemy fast food franchise burger
king entered its vicinity the creature
vomited a stream of hot coffee at the
corporate interloper like a fire hose
until he left suggesting that it does
have some kind of strange inherent
loyalty to the mcdonald's company but
still other than this isolated incident
the creature has never even displayed
sentience it was a big strange clownish
mcdonald's food dispenser when
questioned about the origins of scp-5962
mr chen once again underplayed the
strangeness of the situation saying that
he'd heard rumors the farm that sold him
scp-5962 and also sold other strange
anomalous creatures to eager buyers in
the u.s the farm which we can only
assume is situated right next to a
radioactive waste dump was also behind
scp-4158
also known as big charlie
this giant omnivorous and seemingly
immortal mutant cow is believed to have
been birthed from a non-anomalous cow
sold to the butcher's block
slaughterhouse it looked hideous and
seemed to suffer from a wide variety of
health issues leading to the employees
at the slaughterhouse trying to put the
creature out of its misery however no
matter how hard they tried to kill the
monster it just wouldn't die its bones
were pretty much indestructible and no
matter how much of its flesh was cut off
it just kept growing back causing no ill
effects to the creature itself
eventually the slaughterhouse workers
tried cooking and eating the meat
leading to them discovering it tasted
just as good as non-anomalous meat much
like the chinese mcdonald's and scp-5962
the workers had just hit the lottery
with big charlie as long as they kept
feeding the monster which ate everything
from bricks to other non-anomalous cows
it provided a pretty much limitless
supply of meat giving them unprecedented
economic prosperity in other words big
charlie was a literal cash cow jeff fine
the slaughterhouse director even started
worshiping big charlie as a kind of
demigod by drinking his blood he
believed that big charlie was a savior
sent to lift them all out of their
struggle and desperation sadly for them
the scp foundation sent them right back
when big charlie escaped their
slaughterhouse and foundation field
agents found secured and contained it it
was a sad day for the butcher's block so
what have we learned today whether
you're in the u.s of a or the chinese
heartland if you're chowing down on fast
food you really have no idea where it
came from i mean we kind of knew that
already but for all we know the food
you're enjoying could have just been
vomited up by a giant fat clown or cut
from the flesh of a mutated cow just
think about that next time you're
enjoying a burger but hey let's be
honest with ourselves we'll all probably
still eat it whether these are five-star
luxury suites or seedy roach motels
there's something undeniably a little
eerie about hotels they're liminal
spaces transitional spots between
origins and destinations we've seen
countless creepy hotel rooms in the
horror genre from room 237 in the
shinings overlook hotel to the infamous
room
1408 but have you ever heard of room 710
also known by a different number
scp-2432 this hotel room is one of the
most terrifying out there but the funny
thing is you won't ever hear a bad word
said about it room 710 has glowing if a
little strangely worded reviews across
the board and when you see how people
rave about it online you'll find
yourself unable to resist paying it a
visit but don't be nervous all these
people can't be wrong right and after
all it's just a room what kind of harm
could a room really do
let's ask chuck peel one of the many
victims of scp-2432
he was a traveling businessman caught in
the rat race of relentless sales pitches
and conferences that felt like they were
slowly but surely sucking out his soul
his next conference was in state college
pennsylvania and he'd spend the evening
researching different places he could
potentially stay during the trip chuck
had been disenchanted with chain hotels
over the years seeing the exact same
setups again and again all across the
country only worsened the feeling that
his life was going nowhere that's why
whenever he was traveling out of town he
always tried to find an interesting
independent place to hang his hat that's
what led him to the redacted hotel the
pictures seemed nice sure but what
really caught his eye were the
positively fantastic reviews little note
certain details have been redacted to
avoid subjecting you the viewer to the
memetic effects nested in these reviews
after all we wouldn't want you to
develop a sudden hankering for room 710
and start buying your tickets to state
college pennsylvania the first review
found on tripadvisor said another great
stay in this fabulous hotel the room was
perfect the staff friendly as always and
of course no better location than on
this plane of many hives i've enjoyed a
drink at the friendly bar this time i
added a wonderful escape and breakfast
was cold and breakfast was warm the
restaurant has lovely ambience and the
food was over the top alive and kicking
wood stifle again my husband eats out
often and felt that this was one of the
best one ever another great stay in this
fabulous hotel one more great item to
add to the redacted another great stay
in this fabulous hotel stage july 1999
traveled with three family members the
second review this time posted on yelp
red we sailed on our boat into state
college from outside state college
through the night and the cold and
arrived at 8 a.m in state college the
hotel desk staff allowed us to check in
and out 8 am in the evening with our 64
young boys this was absolutely awesome
awesome customer service we can't thank
you enough for allowing us to check in
oh so early in state college earlier
than war the rest of the stay was fine
we spent almost all of our time in the
room mostly just to sleep this location
is ultra ultra convenient with downtown
downtown state college and allowed me to
make a midnight run for some of my
favorite state college meet while the
family was sleeping and sleeping and
sleeping and sleeping
in state college downtown redacted
downtown and the final review which
chuck peale found particularly
compelling red been coming to this
region for 14 stone what a blast scores
of humans wandering the streets and
staffing the hotel my husband and my
husband and i have walked drooling path
to get here bed in room 710 was soft and
cozy and appreciated the decor would
recommend the bed and specifically the
bed and specifically the bed redacted in
the pool and it was lovely crisp blue
hydrogen and you could see all the
people relax into a meandering menace
tau slightly dirty gym was full of
usable equipment so you could train not
in fear and the local wildlife was
remarkable i visited the town in the
past and have not seen many puma being
feasted on redacted and the toucan men
were especially numerous today arrived
july 2019 staying three days months 10
years well these may seem like utter
nonsense to you to someone reading them
without the key memetic trigger phrases
redacted they create an irresistible
urge to visit the hotel and stay in room
710 it was an urge so primal and
powerful that he couldn't wait to get
going if only because he could finally
stay in this wonderful hotel and see
what all this fuss was about he booked
his tickets and a few days later he was
at the check-in desk something you need
to understand is that room 710 is
extremely subtle in its anomalous
methods unlike room 237 or room 1408 it
won't attack the victims with ghosts or
mind-warping hallucinations nor will it
drive them into acts of horrific
violence against the ones they love or
acts of self-destruction one of the
frightening things about room 710 is
that while you're actually inside it you
can have an extremely pleasant stay it's
only once you leave that things start
becoming truly terrifying but we'll get
to that when we get to it chuck made his
way up to the room to take a shower and
take the weight off his feet and sure
enough the room seemed positively
luxurious two queen-sized beds with fine
linen a spacious closet a large flat
screen television and a well-appointed
bathroom with a combo shower bath this
was heaven sure it was one more bed than
he needed but this meant he had a choice
of which one he could sleep on
fantastic
this is the insidious power of scp-24
there's nothing overt about the harm it
causes at first chuck was more worried
about the impending conference than he
was about the fact he was in the belly
of the anomalous beast however the scp
foundation through later analysis of the
room
found that the anomalous elements aren't
entirely ephemeral there are certain
details about the physical makeup of the
room that causes and amplifies its
effects the walls are reinforced with
hyperstrong aramid fibers and it's
believed that the very makeup of the
room serves to create mind-warping
oscillations that are undetectable to
the conscious mind but are particularly
potent when the victim is asleep chuck
didn't know it but every moment he spent
in that room it was crawling into his
head just that little bit more he was
already subconsciously composing his
nonsensical memetic review of the place
as the night drew to a close chuck
decided to relax and enjoy some
television the hotel's website posted a
wide variety of channels after all but
after switching through a few different
channels he came to rest at a channel
simply called room news it was simple
but soothing an image of a sailboat in
the middle of a pastoral lake while what
sounded like cheerful elevator music
played chuck simply sat and enjoyed the
relaxing ambiance for a moment before
the music was interrupted by a deep
british voice who began delivering a
strange monologue for reasons he
couldn't quite explain chuck felt that
this voice was speaking directly to him
let me describe something to you
this is a true story it really happened
to me it could have happened to you
every day you wake up and you go to your
job and there's just something off about
your boss he's weird and clingy and
strange your workers are nice enough but
they don't communicate they are quiet
and out of it and absorbed in their own
little worlds and you are ignored not
because you are ugly or awkward or rude
but because you are there
and you suspect things about your
co-workers despite their habits and
strange things each of them places on
their twitter pages they seem to be
doing so much better than you how are
you falling behind and you should love
the job it is your passion most would
die to be doing a job they are
passionate about you really should but
you can't wonder becomes routine and
routine becomes drudgery and it's day in
and day out and you struggle to maintain
your soul
this is not what should happen
should is such a tormenting word a
thinking trap should your life is ruled
by shoulds you come home in your beat up
old car along the same boring street in
your town everything is along that main
drag and you cannot really go elsewhere
everything is overcast and the
pedestrians are idiots and the drivers
are too you get home and have a million
billion projects to accomplish you
should compete in the rat race but
you're bone tired you promise your
grandmother you should text her because
she's going through chemo and she only
just figured out texting because she's
getting old and having a hard time
adjusting and it's oh so painful for her
and you should be there but the job is
so demanding you have a thousand books
you should be reading you have a million
projects you should complete the rent on
your tiny apartment is due when the
dishes are piling high and dirty in the
sink you barely have enough money for
pizza as you lie in your boxers on your
greasy ten-year-old couch from an ikea
in fishkill new york that closed a year
ago you remember your mom taking you
there as a kid then she left you feel a
deep growing anxiety the feeling of
watching your life burn around you as
you try and succeed for something great
to make your mark on society but you
cannot bring yourself to do so despite
your convictions the dread is horrible
it's all crumbling apart the parade is
passing you by and you are helpless
immobile in your state like a great
boulder made of disappointment regret
depression and malaise
there is nothing for you here you need
to leave this place you have a choice
get your good clean shirt and your smart
pants and announce you are taking a
break don't even pack don't even bring
your phone one simple call to the office
and get on your way take that beat up
old car from the garage underneath your
apartment complex give your cat the last
of his food and some water and hit the
road leave the town and your ex and the
promises you made and your job and your
grandmother and your responsibilities
and worries what i recommend you do is
simple find a hotel not a motel or
something shabby a hotel even a chain
will do hotels are simply remarkable
aren't they clean and elegant all
modernistic and designed to appeal in
the eye you don't even need to care
about a thing in the world food is
provided they clean up after you and you
can feel like you have some luxury for
once most even have pools and fitness
centers where you can finally get in
shape and pick your life up it's a
chance to step back and regroup take a
look at the customers around you
travelers most strange people
interesting people people you won't ever
see again travel is so romantic so
mysterious my what stories these people
probably have and the staff also all are
so attentive in the smart little
uniforms don't listen to the naysayers
these people all love their jobs you
know they do
the room is amazing the wallpaper is
elegant and the paintings make you feel
at ease there are clean towels every day
and the bed is freshly made you can
escape the oncoming storm outside the
thunder crashing down on the roof like
ball bearings you could live your whole
life in this place enjoy the sugary
cereals at the breakfast buffet get a
loyalty card and pay no money traveling
really changes a man relaxes him shapes
him up into a better person you become a
better person by staying in a hotel
strong social a proper soldier you adapt
to the hotel mindset enjoy the soft
music and eat that fresh waffle grab a
beer in the evening with your fellow
transients from the attached sports bar
relax and watch that old showing of that
superhero movie on your tv
live here forever enjoy the hotel become
the hotel never leave why would you want
to leave even when you do walk out of
these pristine glass sliding doors you
are empty the hotel is in your soul now
and you feel a worse person away from it
you feel yourself slipping back into
that gray life a black hole is in your
heart your soul is the hotel your
consciousness is the hotel you are now
one with your accommodations you are
your accommodations are your life
ascend isn't that lovely as he fell
asleep chuck found himself nodding yes
yes that is lovely how nice it would be
to ascend little did he know he was
receiving a broadcast from scp-2432-1
a small boil-like creature affixed to
the back of the television foundation
tests have revealed that this creature
is made from a mix of human rockfish and
pig-like dna it only causes strange
broadcasts when affixed to the back of
this particular television but that's
fine chuck rather enjoyed the show it
gave him a lot to think about he left
the hotel a changed man a few days later
once the conference was finally over and
gave it a glowing review it was not long
after he'd returned home that he began
to notice the changes taking place
nothing extreme at first just gaining
some weight and then a little stranger
he began to develop a purple rash that
just wouldn't go away as the rash
worsened it seemed to take on almost a
floral pattern chucked it in mind if
ever you asked him he'd just murmur
something about ascending then the
changes got worse a television-shaped
protrusion made from bone began to grow
in chuck's stomach his intestines became
rickety porcelain pipes his liver turned
into a plush well-fluffed pillow his
muscles began to take on a similar
quality to the aramid fibers in the
walls of room 710 but still he didn't
mind
as he got bigger and bigger he didn't
mind as his organs and bones transformed
into furniture inside him he didn't mind
he didn't even mind when his body got so
large that it formed a roughly cube-like
shape in fact he couldn't be happier he
was just like that room that beautiful
wonderful room just like the man on the
television said he was now one with the
accommodation and he couldn't be happier
he'd never much enjoyed being a human
anyway such is the fate of everyone who
stays in
scp-2432 eventually you'll love the room
so much that eventually you'll start
emulating it sure that may seem
frightening to you now but don't worry
on the other end of the transformation
you'll be much more
accommodating you're right in the middle
of one of the hottest summers on record
the days are filled with bright
scorching sun and searing heat and
you've been laying around with your air
conditioning on full blast just to try
and cool yourself off sadly it's not
really working and the heat is becoming
way too much but then you remember
there's this married couple that lives
near you with no kids and they happen to
have a swimming pool in their yard
normally they keep to themselves they'd
never let you use their pool but they've
gone out of town for a few days besides
the heat is killing you you're sure that
the neighbors wouldn't mind if you just
took a quick dip as long as you clean up
after yourself they probably wouldn't
even notice you were even there
cautiously you make your way to their
house it's an unremarkable place similar
to most of the other houses in this
suburb of new mexico after checking that
there's nobody else around you climb the
two meter high cinderblock wall that
stands around the back garden as you
drop to your feet sweaty and panting
from the unrelenting summer heat you see
it the pool your salvation water never
looks so appealing immediately you step
barefoot across the sun-scorched tiles
and sit on the edge legs in the water
it's cool and refreshing perfect for a
day as hot as today you're already
changed and wearing your swim trunks so
it doesn't take long for you to paddle
out to the middle of the pool letting
that chilled clean water cool you off as
you're taking a dip you notice the
pool's jets turning on automatically
it's a little bit odd but you shrug it
off that couple clearly shelled out for
a pool with a lot of fancy bells and
whistles but extra features aren't why
you're here you came because if you
didn't then you could have melted under
all that sunlight floating on the
surface of the water you relax with your
arms behind your head and close your
eyes you don't have time to realize that
coming here was a mistake instead you
start to feel relaxed so calm so
tranquil you're one with the water
around you now it's almost as though you
could just disappear
so
you do
the police never find any trace of you
everyone else simply writes it off as a
random disappearance there's not even so
much as a scrap of your body left in the
pool
just the clear clean water why because
the swimming pool you decided to take a
cooling dip in wasn't an ordinary pool
it was scp-242
but don't worry you won't be the last to
make that costly mistake what you didn't
know is that the married couple who live
in that house are secretly a pair of scp
foundation doctors the house isn't even
theirs the foundation procured it after
the former owner a retired out-of-state
landlord strangely vanished he had been
struggling to find anyone to rent the
place so he eventually decided to give
up on the property game and move in
there himself after three days he was
never seen again now that house has only
one rule that must be followed above all
else do not swim in the pool
scp-242 is at least to the untrained eye
just an average swimming pool a decent
nine meters in length four and a half
wide and it holds around 53 000 liters
of sterile pool water like we mentioned
before it's even got some nifty features
like water jets a dual waterfall and a
built-in vacuum unit for sucking out any
impurities and we mean any impurities
you see
scp-242 does go by another name the
self-cleaning pool and while that might
not sound as foreboding or dramatic as
the scarlet king or the wendigo skull or
the horrifying nasty dude of ultimate
badness okay we made that last one up we
can assure you that you don't ever want
to suffer the fate of taking a swim in
this pool there was an incident a while
ago recorded by the foundation through a
secret hidden camera the house where
scp-242 can be found had been left
vacant for a time and once again some
opportunists decided to take advantage
of the empty swimming pool this time it
was a couple a man and a woman in their
early twenties they climbed up the back
wall undressed and even stole a couple
of plastic inflatable rafts from a shed
in the house's backyard the water jets
switched themselves on startling the
girl but her boyfriend told her not to
worry the filter to clean the pool was
probably just on an automatic timer
right surely it wouldn't have been
anything to worry about after swimming
together for around 24 minutes the
couple both agreed that the water felt
warm tingly even both of them climbed
onto their rafts eventually falling
asleep while still holding each other's
hands but almost half an hour after the
jets had started something caused the
two rafts to burst the couple awoke
startled by the loud pop of the
splitting inflatables and being plunged
back into the water the pool around them
immediately began frothing violently and
deep red streams of blood swirling
through the water as the couple screamed
in fear and agony both of them tried to
desperately swim to the edge hoping to
leave the pool and get to safety but
unfortunately that plan didn't work
before they could reach the edge the man
and the woman were pulled under the
surface of the raging water their limbs
thrashing as they still tried in vain to
escape eventually they vanished under
the crimson bloody water the frothing
slowly began to calm and the red in the
pool dissipated once again becoming
clear after 48 seconds the couple were
never seen again and a cover story was
leaked to the press by the scp
foundation two weeks after they went
missing according to them the pair had a
lope together somewhere in mexico if
only that sounds a lot nicer than what
actually happened to them so this
swimming pool clearly has some anomalous
properties that much is obvious but what
exactly are those properties how exactly
does scp-242 work is it an
interdimensional gateway that drags
people to a nasty alternate universe if
they spend too long swimming in it or is
the swimming pool itself a sentient
carnivorous creature that lures humans
in only to devour them maybe the water
is teeming with invisible flesh-eating
piranhas that can strip the meat from
the bone in a matter of seconds well
good guesses all around but actually
it's none of these
it's unclear what causes the pool's
anomalous effects it could be a property
that is completely unique to the water
contained in scp-242
or maybe it's down to the exact shape
and measurements of the pool itself it
could even be a combination of both but
whatever the cause the result is always
the same when any object substance or
even living organism is placed in
scp-242
it will be entirely rewritten on a
molecular level the genetic and atomic
structure will fall apart and the
subject will be transmuted into sterile
water in fact not just clean water but
water that remains sterile even when
removed from the pool if you took a cup
of scp-242's water and mix something
like food coloring into it the food
coloring would not be absorbed into the
water instead staying as one
non-miscible bubble this process doesn't
happen instantly though it can vary
depending on how contaminated or complex
the substance placed in scp-242
is for example water sampled from a
nearby river was sterilized and purified
by the pool in about seven minutes a
sample of stagnant pond water riddled
with various diseases and germs took 11
minutes longer what about 50 000 liters
of coal tar well that one took a little
longer 12 long days to be exact but was
still turned into pure sterile water and
as for a living human being maybe ask
that couple that took a dip in the
self-cleaning pool the foundation is
naturally fascinated with the pool and
after extensive examination they have
determined that scp-242 doesn't seem to
have been intentionally designed for the
specific anomalous function it performs
the components of scp-242 beyond the
pool itself the filter the vacuum the
pipes none of these parts nor anything
about the swimming pool's design appear
to be responsible for disintegrating
matter until only water remains you
might have noticed that in the case of
the ill-fated couple who took a swim in
scp-242 the water jets and waterfall
features switch themselves on
automatically before the pair's grim
demise somehow these features are able
to activate without the need for
electricity as disconnecting the pool
from a power source will not stop the
jets and waterfall from coming on once a
non-water substance is placed into
scp-242
the same goes for the pool vacuum which
apparently cannot be jammed or
malfunctioned even when the bottom of
the pool is awash with viscous liquids
like that coal tar the vacuum will
continue to operate as normal scrubbing
away at the floor of scp-242
the one part of the self-cleaning pool
that doesn't work as you would expect is
the water filtration system there is
never any water being cycled into the
pool nor out of it as a matter of fact
the pipes connecting to the filtration
system have all been removed then again
who needs a filtration system when your
backyard swimming pool can just
spontaneously reduce anything to clean
water but that raise is another
frightening thought everything that the
pool has ever taken and converted is
still in there animals objects people
just swimming around you perhaps if they
could still think they'd scream and
shout and tell you to get away to run
while you still can but the second your
skin touches the water you're destined
to be with them forever
and ever and ever it's enough to send a
liquid chill down your spine okay so if
it's not the actual physical pool that
causes these anomalous effects that must
mean it's something in the water right
perhaps some microscopic flesh devouring
microbe or some ancient curse that was
placed on the water before it was used
to fill up the pool surely if you took a
cup of water out of scp-242
it would still break down structures on
a molecular level leaving only more
sterile water while the researchers
working at the scp foundation thought
much of the same and conducted a series
of tests to determine the exact
properties of
scp-242's water one test involves
submerging two d-class test subjects
each wearing an atmospheric dive suit
into
scp-242 the goal was to determine if it
was safe to consume the water from
scp-242 while both inside and outside of
the pool test subject a was lowered into
the water and instructed to drink from a
metal straw by their mouth the eyepieces
of their goggles were blacked out so
they couldn't see what they were
drinking from subject b filled a barrel
with the same water from scp-242
and then was made to put on an
atmospheric dive suit but instructed to
stay out of the pool test subject a was
told to drink directly from the pool
remarking that the water was warm and
had a bit of a noticeable chemical
aftertaste but was otherwise normal then
test subject b drank some of the same
water from the barrel apparently it was
cool and tasted of
well nothing just like water usually
does after a moment more of drink
subject a began belching finding that
they had uncontrollable gas the water
had begun to feel warmer stinging the
subject's mouth while for subject b the
water from the barrel stayed cool and
refreshing the foundation doctors
overseeing the experiment instructed
test subject a to keep drinking which
they did until it felt even hotter to
the taste one of the d-class's fillings
even fell out and eventually the
structural integrity of subject a's dive
suit failed presumably disintegrated by
the water from scp-242
after a few muffled screams and gurgling
noises test subject a wasn't heard from
again and we can all probably guess why
as for subject b they kept drinking from
the barrel suffering no adverse effects
even after 17 long hours there were no
noticeable psychological or physical
changes even their urine showed no
traces of abnormality the water from
scp-242 left in the barrel evaporated as
normal leaving behind no residue or any
indicator as to why taking the water out
of the pool made it safer to drink than
the same water in the pool perhaps the
moral of the story is to just be careful
where you choose to take a swim
otherwise it could be
your last
it was just an ordinary night at site 19
and dr smith was hard at work in his
office the overhead light was just about
ready to give out the bulb dim and
flickering but there was no one
available to change it at the moment so
he would just make do besides he only
had a little bit of work left to finish
hunched over his desk eyes blurry and
head aching from too many hours of
staring at a screen he was ready to wrap
up this report and finally get home for
some well-deserved rest the constant
anxiety of working with some of the
scariest monsters in the world was one
thing but the hour spent writing
paperwork on the monsters was an
altogether different kind of terrifying
most of the research staff had left for
the night and only dr smith and the
usual security team remained in the
building there was no sound except the
click of his fingers on the keys his
occasional exhausted sigh and the
infrequent sound of footsteps in the
hall outside as a security officer made
his rounds dr smith leaned back in his
chair stretching his arms over his head
and feeling his back crack almost done
he recalled dimly a thermos of tea he
had left on the shelf behind him perhaps
that would be the kick he needed to
finish this work up and get home to his
bath his books and his pet cat roger he
swiveled his chair around preparing to
stand up and retrieve the thermos when
he suddenly came face to face with a
nightmare
there less than an inch from him was a
smooth featureless face
black as the night and devoid of any
expression it was hunched over its face
peering into him despite not having any
eyes itself without a sound without so
much as a creak of the door this thing
had come into his office and appeared
behind him waiting for him to turn
around and see it dr smith let out a
shriek of terror knocking his chair over
as he scrambled to get away from the
intruder his heart pounding in his ears
he tore past the dark figure yanking
open the door to his office and taking
off running down the hall he called out
for help for someone anyone to come
several security personnel heard his
cries and rushed to see what had
happened they found a shivering dr smith
babbling about a demon in his office and
repeating it doesn't have a face over
and over again once he had calmed down
and finally been given that cup of tea
dr smith was informed that as stressful
as that encounter might have been he was
never really in any danger we don't have
another scp-173 on our hands here
thankfully this statue isn't murderous
or even violent to the best of our
observational ability we've determined
that this particular surprisingly mobile
statue is just kind of a jerk scp-650
nicknamed the startling statue is a
stylized black statue of a humanoid
figure standing at 167 centimeters tall
it has no hands or facial features its
arms extending in rounded points and its
face and head a smooth surface like that
of a mannequin when the statue is
dormant or at least resting and waiting
for its next chance to move it stands
straight and reaches upwards head tilted
up as if its non-existent eyes are
watching the sky attempts to determine
the materials of the statue is made of
have proved inconclusive some tests show
an impossibly large combination of
different materials where other tests
came back with no matches for any
recognized materials at all if no one is
observing the statue it will move to a
place immediately behind whoever is in
the room with it switching its pose to a
more threatening one it moves silently
and no one has been able to capture
evidence of its method of locomotion all
that is known is that it does in fact
move and it always appears extremely
close to the subject of its interest in
order to provoke a strong flight or
fight reaction the statue seems to have
no interest in harming those it
frightens never touching or directly
interacting with anyone it only seems
interested in startling its victims if
you can even call them victims it can be
unpleasant to be unexpectedly frightened
like that sure but you get the same
experience at most halloween attractions
or horror movies and people pay good
money for those several trials were
conducted in order to determine the
statue's pattern of behavior in a trial
an scp foundation agent was assigned to
stand in the statue's containment unit
and watch the object for a period of
time when prompted by a researcher in
another room speaking to them via radio
they were ordered to look away from the
statue once cleared to look at the
statue again they were ordered to look
around the room and report where it went
and what it was doing in most of the
experiments the statue appeared directly
behind the personnel angled with its
arms reaching towards them and its head
glaring down at them as if about to
attack in nearly every trial the statue
hit the same position and the agent
looking at it was startled to the point
of screaming there was even talk of
cutting footage of all the screams
together into a video that would be
shown at the company christmas party
however in three cases the statue
adopted a different pose as well as a
position in the room much to the
surprise and confusion of the team
conducting the experiments when agent
dunn was assigned to observe the statue
he was asked to close his eyes for five
seconds and wait for scp-650 to move
when he opened his eyes the first thing
he did was whirl around and look behind
him having heard about the results of
the previous tests however when he
turned to face the statue there was
nothing there he turned back around to
his original stance preparing to radio
command and tell them the statue was
gone when he let out a yelp of surprise
there at the table in the corner several
feet away was the statue it was lying on
the table with its arms behind its head
as if relaxing with the area considered
to be its face turned directly towards
dunn unsettled by the surprise and
definitely uncomfortable with how the
statue seemed to be looking at him he
left the room without another word at
another point in the trials agent riley
pulled the short straw and was told to
enter 650's containment she stood in the
center of the room and stared at the
statue in front of her for a long period
of time when given the command she
closed her eyes and waited for a
duration of 30 seconds much like agent
dunn her first instinct on opening her
eyes was to turn around and look behind
her ready to see the statue there
instead however it was sitting on a
chair at the other end of the room the
points where its hands should be neatly
folded in its lap its body was facing
away from agent riley but even though
she was looking at what could have
easily been the back of the statue's
head she later reported the distinct
sense that it was looking at her though
she didn't scream like her collies had
when it was their turn to watch the
statue she confessed to feeling an
overwhelming sense of unease and her
hands would not stop shaking for the
next several hours these two instances
of the statue adopting a casual posture
and keeping its distance from its
observers were bizarre but the final
break from the statue's usual behavior
was the strangest of them all agent cho
was sent into scp-650s containment and
told the stand with his back against the
wall of his choice the plan was to
determine what the statue would do if
its unusual favorite position just
behind the observer was no longer an
option if there was no space behind
agent cho then the statue could not turn
up there once he was settled into his
spot and had been watching the statue
for several minutes agent cho closed his
eyes for exactly one minute when he
opened them he immediately scanned the
room to see where the statue had gone it
was not at the table or the chair nor
was it standing in its original place in
front of him finally he spotted it the
statue was huddled in the corner of the
room curled up in an approximation of
the fetal position its head was down and
its arms were held up in front of its
face as if trying to protect itself
though he could not explain why agent
cho got a distinct impression that the
statue was afraid his stomach dropped at
the site and he would later admit to his
supervisor that he briefly thought about
trying to comfort as cp 650 somehow the
impulse passed but cho was left with a
mixture of anxiety and guilt as if he
had done something wrong and upset the
statue the sensation did not pass until
he was out of the room it is not
entirely clear why the statue chose
these alternative poses during these
particular experiments the prevailing
theory among the research team is that
these are simply other tools in its
arsenal methods that it can use to
elicit a strong reaction from a person
who is less likely to be startled by its
usual trick following the incident with
dr smith
scp-650 was upgraded from safe class to
euclid class just to clarify for people
in the back euclid-class scps are not
necessarily considered to be dangerous
but require more effort to contain than
objects classified as safe most scps
that display autonomy or independent
thought but are not overtly hostile
towards humanity are classified as
euclid along with its updated status
special containment procedures have been
employed in order to keep this startling
statue from making any more surprise
escapes
scp-650 is to be stored in a locked room
four meters by four meters it is to be
kept under constant surveillance by at
least three personnel at any given time
standing so that the scp and at least
one of the observers are visible to them
at all times they are allowed to watch
the statue remotely via security camera
as long as they remain focused on the
scp this method is only to be employed
in case of emergency a great deal of the
foundation's budget was dedicated to
maintaining up-to-date containment
facilities for scp-650
as demanded in a note from dr smith in
the official file for scp-650
the note reads i don't give a flying rat
about the budget keep this damn thing
contained turning around in a dim office
to see this thing a half inch away from
your nose is guaranteed to take years
from your life and given what we deal
with we don't have many to spare so what
does the startling statue want why does
it use its power of mobility to scare
people but never do anything beyond that
no one is certain and the foundation has
too many other fires to put out to
bother looking further into a clearly
benign entity unfortunately there are
questions about scp-650 that will never
be answered and there is so much about
it we will never know one thing is for
sure though if you find yourself alone
in a room with an unsettling statue you
had better keep an eye on it just in
case
[Laughter]
well hello there boyers and ghouls we
hope we didn't startle you too hard
there it's only us your good old friends
at scp explained we all love a little
fright now and then don't we after all
that would explain our fascination with
the morbid tales of the scp foundation
rotten old men who can walk through
walls and tear you limb from limb in
their own private house nightmarish
circuit diseases that turn anyone who
touches them into a horrible abomination
evil masks that kill you and take over
your body using it to do acts of great
cruelty until you melt down into black
goo oh
you're not scared of those
you think you're so tough so prepared
for anything that even those anomalous
beings of pure terror can't break
through the impenetrable shell of your
bravery well
i suppose we better bring out the big
guns then
just remember when you're huddled in the
corner bones rattling in fear that you
brought this on yourself
after all
there's no entity quite as good as
inspiring screams as scp 2006
so please stay awhile and find out why
this one's called too spooky
we're sorry you had to hear that but you
really can't blame us for having a
little theatricality with this one in
fact having a good grasp of
theatricality is actually essential to
everyone dealing with scp-2006
forget gunplay rituals and mind games
scp-2006 requires foundation subsidized
acting lessons in order to work on his
containment which even as foundation
containment methods go is pretty darn
strange when you got into this line of
work you probably expected you'd be in
high intensity battles with scp-682
or attending conferences on how to best
repel the menace of the scarlet king not
acting out scenes from a streetcar named
desire with dr bright but believe us
it's important work as they'll probably
tell you at these classes there are no
small parts only small actors you won't
spend time at these sessions perfecting
shakespearean soliloquies instead you'll
be adopting a much narrower focus
learning how to properly act and express
fear the more convincingly scared you
can appear the better because when it
comes to
scp-2006 your job and potentially even
your life depend on it plus it's the
only time that being your pants and
collapsing on the job may actually get
you a raise rather than just a series of
strange looks from your co-workers when
you pass that course with flying colors
you'll finally be ready to actually come
face to face with the prince of
nightmares himself
scp-2006 by this point you've had it
drilled into your head so many times
that you could never forget it for the
love of god whatever this thing does you
act scared don't stonewall don't smile
and whatever you do don't laugh laughing
at scp-2006 is probably the fastest way
you can get demoted to swabbing feces in
scp-173's
chamber if you know what's good for you
you'll dial up that fear when the big
day comes you're sent into
scp-2006's airtight containment chamber
with a special package that time of the
month has come once again you need to
deliver the goods you spot a television
in the corner first still on but tuned
to static you're pondering what a waste
of electricity this is when
scp-2006 who'd been hiding behind an
armchair decided to finally strike he
barely had time to realize what was
going on when a large dark shape
suddenly blotted out your vision it was
over six feet tall and looked well it
looked like a man in an exceedingly
cheap gorilla costume except with a
goofy diving helmet with what looked
like tv antennas on top it waved its
arms wildly as if to hammer home the
point that yes this really was happening
and you should be terrified by it the
creature bellowed fear me mortal i am
the mighty roman cower in fear
at that moment your weeks of training
kicked in almost like a reflex you let
out an ear piercing shriek and drop down
to the floor desperately crawling away
from the goofy looking creature eyes
wide breathing heavy moments frantic and
defensive you gather yourself up in one
of the room's corners and curl into a
ball covering your face imbuing your
voice with a well-practiced quiver you
say please mighty roman don't hurt me i
have so much to live for just please let
me go the monster holds a quote-unquote
menacing pose for a few seconds longer
before slackening into a joyful laugh it
even extended a rubbery gorilla paw to
help you up of course you hesitate for a
few seconds gazing fearfully waiting for
it to say
it's just me doc i got you pretty good
didn't i and as far as he knows yes he
did you're sure to never slip into the
body language of comfort it's utterly
vital that scp-2006 truly believes that
he's scary to you even though he looks
like a terrible monster costume from an
even worse low-budget b-movie though
specifically the roman the monster from
the 1950 trash classic robot monster you
tell scp 2006 that you're here with some
more stimulus material for him and hand
him a plastic bag when he asks you what
you've brought him this time you tell
him you can't even look at it if you so
much has laid eyes on it you'd slip into
a terrified state of catatonia you'd
honestly rather look at 096 than look at
what you've brought him today scp 2006
cocked his head to the side and asked
what's 096 oh
no
the terror that was fake before wasn't
quite so fake now you'd slipped up buddy
and if you didn't come up with a good
save quickly you would be in deep
trouble you gulp and take a quick breath
trying to compose yourself before saying
that 096 is just another movie one
that's not nearly as scary as the one
you've prepared for him it seemed to
satisfy him so you internally breathe a
sigh of relief and turn to make your
exit you've just left
scp-2006 with a dvd copy of the 1977
classic deathbed the bed that eats a
somewhat obscure horror movie about an
evil bed created by a demon that should
tie the eccentric anomaly over for
another month so you're probably
wondering what actually just happened
what's the logic what are the
connections between the strange sequence
of events we all just witnessed well it
may seem bizarre now once you know more
about
scp-2006 it'll all make sense we can't
promise it'll actually seem any less
bizarre by the end though
scp-2006 is a ketter-class
shape-shifting anomaly its default form
is a floating sphere of about 50
centimeters in diameter not exactly
terrifying and this is actually a big
problem for scp-2000
as the mischievous anomaly has an almost
compulsive desire to scare people not to
physically harm them in any way just
give them a good old-fashioned spook
he's shown to be pretty much
indestructible so neutralization is off
the table you may be thinking he seems
like a pretty harmless goofball why
would anyone want to neutralize him and
well we'll answer that one later back to
scp-2006's favorite hobby scaring people
while 2006 seems to practically live off
of giving a good scare he's thankfully
no pennywise 2006 has no inherent
knowledge of what scares humans and thus
has to learn what scares humans from
external sources this unique weakness to
scp-2006's ability is one the foundation
has discovered as an ingenious method of
exploiting for its containment they
simply keep
scp-2006 misinformed on what people
actually find scary tricking it to make
sure that it's always hopelessly inept
at its hobby their method of achieving
this is twofold firstly they give
scp-2006 a monthly supply of the worst
horror movies you can imagine true
bargain bucket b-movie schlock troll 2
leprechaun in the hood birdemic shock
and terror a personal favorite the
ginger dead man the beast of yucca flats
plan 9 from outer space a runner-up for
me the creeping terror the man without a
body manos the hands of fate track of
the moon beast and of course the seminal
classic iga a movie about an evil
caveman being unfrozen and
terrorizing palm springs movies like
this are a perfect mechanism for
tricking scp-2006
because it sees the characters in the
movies reacting with fear to the
terrible hokey monsters rampaging across
backlots and sound stages and starts to
believe that these b-movie beasts are
actually scary that's the first part of
the trick and you've probably already
figured out the second half the
foundation makes sure that any employees
who interact with scp 2006 in any
capacity must play the part of appearing
actually genuinely frightened by it this
one-two punch of trickery keeps scp-2006
successfully bamboozled as such despite
being a creature largely based around
creating fear albeit in a more friendly
playful way than most anomalies it's
seen as a joke among staff members it
wouldn't be surprising to hear that
different staff members took turns
laughing at surveillance footage or that
the latest site halloween party a few
drunken researchers tried to trick
scp-2006 into assuming the form of david
s pumpkins from saturday night live i
believe they also received angry phone
calls from tom hanks's agent the next
day as you could probably gather
developing such an unimpressed attitude
to containing anomalies with the scp
foundation is never a good thing after
all even some of the most innocent
looking ones can hide surprisingly dark
secrets dr randall owings the site
director for site 118 where scp-2006 is
held released a stern memorandum to
everyone working in 2006's proximity it
read i've been getting reports of some
of the lacks behavior regarding scp-2006
many personnel have been heard laughing
at scp-2006 during surveillance when it
watches a new movie or when it attempts
to scare individuals some personnel have
been heard questioning why scp-2006 is
classified as a ketter entity i am here
to remind you that a ketter entity is a
ketter entity regardless of how
innocuous it may seem no scp-2006
is not a rampaging demigod nor is it a
regenerating super lizard however it
possesses the same level of danger as
any other ketter that the foundation has
contained think of scp-2006 scp-2006's
purpose it wishes to scare people
imagine what would happen if scp-2006
broke containment and found out what
really scared people imagine if it saw
the horror and fear of war or the
concepts of paranoia or phobia is common
to each and every human being imagine if
it found the true horror of a nuclear
holocaust or an xk-class scenario now
couple that with an entity that
possesses shape-shifting abilities with
no known limits and you'll understand
why it's classified as ketter all
personnel mentioned above have been
suitably disciplined i do not want to
hear about this again scp-2006
is only as harmless as the foundations
containment procedures allow it to be
it's why it can never know about other
anomalies or any actually frightening
works of fiction if ever
scp-2006 became aware of the true
sources of human fear there would be no
stopping it seeing as the creature
appears to be indestructible like many
of the anomalies kept under lock and key
by the scp foundation it is a ticking
time bomb that one little mistake could
turn into an utter catastrophe terrible
movies and theatrical staff members need
to keep
scp-2006 in the dark about what actually
scares us because beyond that the only
limit to the danger of scp 2006 is the
human imagination and that my friends is
a very spooky thought indeed an scp
foundation researcher sits at a table
inside of a standard containment cell
these are often dangerous places to be
especially when the scp you're supposed
to be studying is one that you can't see
the researcher is taking notes unsure of
exactly what is going to happen next he
can hear the sounds of knives scraping
behind of flesh sizzling and searing
from high heat he braces himself as a
burst of heat hits the back of his head
as if a fireball has erupted
an object floats through the air and
settles in front of him on the table
it's a plate of food and it looks
delicious
it may surprise you to learn that there
is no rule that the scp foundation must
deal exclusively with violent and
vicious creatures not every scp held in
containment shares the same malevolence
and contempt for humanity as scp-682
or the world-ending threat posed by the
likes of scp-2317
some perhaps not many but some are
benign and might even seem outwardly
friendly but you'd still be taking a
huge risk to assume that anything
contained by the scp foundation is
completely harmless such is the case
with
scp-5031 as per the foundation's
containment procedures this
quasi-humanoid meaning it appears to
have some vaguely human features is held
in an airtight cell that is regularly
checked by foundation personnel on a
bi-weekly basis
scp-5031 has no need for regular
nutrition or regular interactions from
staff the trick with scp-5031
is not being eaten by it
since though it doesn't need food it
does still hunt and consume anything it
encounters human or otherwise
avoiding being eaten is hard enough with
creatures that can actually be seen but
like so many other creatures the
foundation keeps contained
scp-5031 has developed an almost perfect
defense mechanism
which is when observed it will literally
cease to exist
some might choose to refer to this as a
quantum lock however it is worth noting
that traces left by scp-5031 still
remain observable when the creature has
temporarily disappeared for example
trails of blood and scratch marks left
behind by scp-5031 still exist when the
scp itself does not
naturally this makes both avoiding the
creature and capturing it using cameras
difficult however when
scp-5031's existence ceases it still
casts a shadow from this researchers
have been able to determine several of
the creature's physical traits
based on its silhouette it has been
deduced that scp-5031 levitates about
half a meter above ground level sports
an abnormally small necklace head atop
an elongated torso approximately 1.9
meters long
with three sets of spindly lower arms
that branch outwards using these arms
and its loosely hanging body
scp-5031 will lower itself to hunt any
human or animal that draws near to it
and uses the blade-like tail to cut up
food
perhaps the most interesting facet of
scp-5031 beyond its defensive
capabilities and apparent physical
attributes
are the series of nine tests conducted
by senior researcher stanley huxtable
appalled by the conditions that the
creature was being kept in huxtable took
over the role of hcl supervisor for
scp-5031
having grown increasingly frustrated and
empathetic towards the creature
listening to its screams from inside its
iron containment unit huxtable devised a
series of tests to introduce scp-5031 to
various different stimuli as a way to
better understand the creature and
hopefully keep it contained in a way
that didn't seem to cause so much
suffering
it's worth remembering that the scp
foundation makes its mission to be cold
not cruel in performing their duties to
protect normality
and many of the researchers and staff
are just as capable of having empathy
for creatures as you might for a stray
animal at a shelter
the first of huxtables tests involved
installing speakers in scp-5031 cell
through which a variety of different
ambient and popular pieces of music were
played to see if they had any effect on
reducing the creature's stress by
judging
scp-5031 stress levels based on how much
it screamed when compared to normal
huxtable was able to determine how to
best use music to calm the creature
scp-5031 seemed to convey higher levels
of stress when listening to morning
forest deep grotto and seaside paradise
ambience
as well as the best of late 60s british
rock band jethro tull however the best
of mozart enya kiss and ben folds
produced dramatically different results
decreasing
scp-5031's apparent stress following
this test senior researcher huxtable
compiled a playlist featuring
scp-5031's favorite music over time the
stress-reducing effects of music on
scp-5031 seemed to decrease
but keeping the playlist on shuffles
seemed to keep the creature consistently
calmer than it had been previously
the next test involved introducing
inanimate objects into
scp-5031's enclosure to monitor its
reactions and how its stress levels were
affected
when a softball was thrown into the
enclosure
scp-5031 immediately sliced the ball in
two with its tail in one swift motion a
similar result occurred when researchers
threw the creature of basketball which
was quickly punctured and sliced open by
scp-5031's tail its stress levels first
seemed to diminish when the creature was
offered a bowling ball which it rolled
around the enclosure and then later
knocked it against a second bowling ball
however when one of the balls chipped
rendering it unable to roll properly
scp-5031 stress increased dramatically
until a replacement was offered
researcher huxtable noted that scp-5031
seemed to possess a similar level of
motor skills to an average human toddler
with similarly explosive emotional
reactions to match
next when given the choice between two
food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure
scp-5031 seemed to gravitate towards
higher quality food most notably favored
cooked rotisserie chickens over animal
carcasses
it even chose this option over a live
chicken using its tail to cut its food
into more manageable bite-sized portions
rather than ripping its meat with its
hands or teeth like many of its fellow
scps
researcher huxtable recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though scp-5031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive
providing the creature with food of a
better quality marginally reduced its
stress
senior researcher huxtable next
attempted to test
scp-5031's coexistence with other living
subjects
each time making sure that the creature
had been adequately fed to avoid any
unseemly incidents
first a live chicken was introduced
scp-5031 rolled its bowling ball at high
speed towards the chicken increasing
both its and the chicken's stress levels
and inadvertently killing the chicken in
the process
when a second chicken was introduced
scp-5031
gently rolled a basketball towards it
but ceased any further engagement after
the chicken squawked from being hit by
the ball next to be introduced into the
enclosure was a blindfolded d-class
staff member who was instructed to sit
down and roll the basketball towards
scp-5031
after doing so for several minutes the
creature began to approach the d-class
subject who was instructed to remove
their blindfold to cease the creature's
existence and prevent any potentially
deadly incidents finally researcher
huxtable had another class d engage in a
game of catch with scp-5031
while facing away from the creature
this test proceeded successfully and
senior researcher huxtable remarked how
scp-5031's motor skills were improving
albeit gradually and with some gentle
encouragement through huxtable's tests
the creature was learning
the next test focused on teaching
scp-5031 linguistic symbols utilized lcd
displays and buttons connected to a food
dispenser one display showed an image of
a rock and the other an image of a
rotisserie chicken after some brief
probing
scp-5031 was quickly able to understand
that pressing the button under the
correct display would dispense a
rotisserie chicken for it to eat the
creature was later able to adapt when
the following day the screen displays
and materials dispensed were swapped and
then later set to swap at random
intervals when additional rock
dispensing stations were introduced this
time displaying the word rock as opposed
to an image
scp-5031 was able to determine which
station dispensed chicken through a
process of elimination whenever the
functions and displays were swapped
scp-5031 would find whichever displayed
the word chicken to receive its food the
final phase of this test presented
scp-5031 with a single station
displaying the word chicken but with a
button that would remain inactive unless
the creature spelled out the same word
with a collection of lettered blocks it
was provided with after some initial
confusion and frustrations as to why the
button would not dispense food when
pressed
scp-5031 was able to assemble the word
correctly not only activating the button
and dispensing food but proving to
researcher huxtable that the creature
was capable of learning language
huxtable continued to test the creature
encouraging it to spell words using
lettered blocks as a method of
communicating by increasing scp-5031's
vocabulary and the amount of human
interaction it received
senior researcher huxtable observed that
scp-5031 was gradually learning to sing
albeit non-verbally as well as to juggle
with its six hands and was even
communicating its food preferences and
dish pairings
later another class d d52125
was introduced to
scp-5031's enclosure to aid in further
testing through
d52125's instructions the creature
quickly learned to draw using crayons
and created artworks depicting itself
its newfound friend d52125
researcher huxtable a cat and a
rotisserie chicken
scp-5031's new creative side didn't stop
there though as the creature quickly
learned to play chopsticks in only two
days once a piano was introduced into
the enclosure
scp-5031 even managed to start creating
its own original admittedly crude
compositions
next a spice rack was placed inside the
creature's cell and d-52125 demonstrated
how to season mead this proved to be
scp-5031's new favorite hobby as it
spent the next three days experimenting
with different combinations of foods and
spices
using its letter blocks to request more
more more garlic powder interestingly
the creature only created artwork or
music when
d52125 was present but seemed to
thoroughly enjoy its experimentation
with food when left alone
following this development senior
researcher huxtable devised a new test
for scp-5031
providing the creature with cooking
utensils and using
d52125 to demonstrate 5031 was shown how
to prepare a variety of different dishes
from hamburgers and tacos to mongolian
beef steak clam chowder and profiteroles
in addition to a small peanut allergy
this eighth test revealed
scp-5031 to be a phenomenal chef
possessing culinary skills far beyond
the average person the creature quickly
and enthusiastically embraced its
newfound talents concocting its very own
brand new recipes with d52125
even volunteering to be the first to
taste test 5031's dishes it was shortly
after this test that
scp-5031 spoke its very first word
and it should come as no surprise that
the word was salt
naturally senior researcher huxtable was
very proud of the progress the creature
had made with its development
the final test almost seemed to be what
the creature was born for over the
course of two months scp-5031 was tasked
with creating a full three-course meal
which would then be served to foundation
staff for thanksgiving
scp-5031 not only rose to the task but
exceeded all of researcher huxtable's
expectations creating a meal that even
gordon ramsay would be hard-pressed to
find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric
next came a beautiful duck confit glazed
luxuriously with apple cider and topped
generously with sweet cranberry compote
paired with a side of butternut squash
gnocchi and served on a bed of kale
seasoned with truffle salt the grand
finale of the exquisite meal was a spice
cassava pie for dessert complemented
with the finest french vanilla ice cream
and a maple hazelnut syrup
an scp scp-5031 didn't stop there the
creature also debuted one of its
original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created as the staff enjoyed the food
scp-5031 performed live from its
enclosure the deeply moving piano
concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher huxtable but
the entire foundation staff as a fitting
end to the creature's tale huxtable
reported that during the thanksgiving
banquet it had created
scp-5031 stress levels reduced entirely
new kinder containment measures that
would keep 50 31 safer but also far more
contented were submitted for approval
perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that scp-5031
isn't simply just another malicious
malevolent monster that the foundation
has to keep under lock and key for the
safety of the world
instead
scp-5031 is a gentle if a little
frightening at first creature that just
requires careful and considered guidance
instead of a cold iron cage and
around-the-clock arm guards through
testing senior researcher stanley
huxtable and his fellow foundation staff
were not only able to help the creature
develop but also found what makes it
tick and not just for the purposes of
containing it instead it is hoped that
scp-5031's creativity and flair for
culinary and musical masterpieces can
continue to thrive and grow
under the proud watch of researcher
huxtable
now for something from the more
terrifying archives of the scp
foundation check out
scp-096 the shy guy or
scp-106 the old man